des succès collègues suis d'origine
québécoise états unis au vilain et je
suis
belle depuis des années moi je suis
originaire de la france une fois par
semaine les professionnels de la
clinique pédiatrique
transculturelle de l'hôpital maisonneuve
rosemont entourent parents des enfants
frappés livre je suis étudiant en
médecine ici les origines et la culture
sont aussi importantes que sont les
signes vitaux d'un patient à l'urgence
on n'est pas dans les soins physiques on
est vraiment dans des problèmes de santé
mentale août secousse sociaux vraiment
plus compliqué ce sont souvent des
familles qui ont un parcours migratoire
vraiment complexe avec des traumatismes
avec des moments de séparation c'est
souvent toute la famille qui a besoin d'
aide pas seulement l'enfant les filles
d'un inventaire haussé de fabio gonzalez
ont été référées à la clinique
transculturelle pour des troubles
anxieux et une perte de poids importante
chez l'une des jumelles de cette langue
d'origine colombienne la famille a vécu
un parcours traumatisant ils sont
arrivés comme réfugié au québec il y a
trois ans denis mon sac et aac à la
confiance sont venus au canada comme
réfugié après un an de consultations
les parents estiment que cette équipe
multidisciplinaire et multiethnique à
changer leur vie la clinique à castres
est très sculptural comment
la clinique transculturelle a été créé
au tournant des années 2000 pour
intervenir avec une meilleure
compréhension du bagage culturel il peut
avoir aussi
des différences culturelles que les
intervenants les médecins ne réussissent
pas à comprendre pour connaître toutes
les toutes les cultures et
il ya aussi des foi des croyants sans
que ce soit religieuse ou mystique qui
peut être déstabilisant pour les
intervenants par exemple un enfant qui
ont un diagnostic d'autisme de parents a
dit maintenant et je pense que quelqu'un
lui aurait envoyé un mauvais sort il
faudrait faire tête traitement avec au
pays d'origine
l'interprète est membre à part entière
de l'équipe d'intervenants même si la
famille parle bien français ou anglais
parce que nous on dit que les choses du
coeur se disent plus facilement dans
leur langue maternelle dans une langue
secondaire les références pour cette
clinique est très particulière ne
cessent d'affluer on a assez de
ressources pour fonctionner seulement
une journée par semaine alors qu'on
aurait du travail pour plus que ça on
peut se demander c'est si bon c'est
beaucoup de ressources à voir tous ces
gens pour une famille mais la richesse
d'un groupe comme ça c'est vraiment
d'apporter différents sens aux problèmes
h signifie amoriell mais mes parents
sont d'origine vietnamienne et l'on
voudrait bien formés plus d'intervenants
à cette approche transculturelle dans le
réseau de la santé ici and with despatie
radio canada montréal